yeah Brian Denise says you might be able
to hear we've traded all those traffic
sounds for construction sounds instead
it's gonna be out for the entire weekend
and if you can look over my shoulder a
site we haven't seen in quite some time
a nearly empty I-15 that ndos says took
years to plan and even though it's just
for over two days drivers could feel it
throughout the valley
it's here if you're watching this now
make sure your friends family and
co-workers are all aware too
both sides of the 15 close until 5 a.m
Monday the concern this bridge built
back in the 60s that the Nevada
Department of Transportation is tearing
down we are tearing down the north half
of the Tropicana Avenue Bridge the lanes
that are currently the westbound Lanes
all of that traffic is being pushed onto
the south side of the bridge the
capacity will be significantly reduced
almost 50 percent a project to raise the
bridge as Federal height requirements
have changed and large trucks
continuously hit it this is what it'll
look like when it reopens a diverging
diamond that briefly reroutes traffic to
the opposite side of the road for direct
access to freeway on-ramps believe it or
not a much more efficient way of moving
vehicles through here with the reduced
Lanes we thought that was pretty
important Lynette Russell is a project
manager who says planning began seven
years ago for just over two days
sometimes you can have freeway traffic
down below but in this case we're taking
down the overpass a portion of it and
that will mean we'll have falling pieces
of concrete and rebar and this is really
a safety measure we don't want people to
get hit with any of our falling debris
and keep them out of the area so we're
protecting them while we do necessary
infrastructure improvements
I asked these officials how many minutes
or hours could we be expected to get
tacked on to our drive this weekend they
say they didn't know the answer to that
so instead I asked them could it look
potentially similar to what we saw over
the Christmas holiday a 12 mile back up
on the I-15 they say that could possibly
be the case for now reporting live for
over the I-15 of Tropicana Ryan Matthey
8 News Now